last time you were here you mentioned
that you would lost 35 pounds I
congratulate our you thank you are you
still still making the effort to be
healthy I am well first I got the Fitbit
I noticed that you got yes and let's see
how I'm doing
oh wait that's the time you know they
want and every day the Fitbit says to me
are you up to 10,000 steps yet I go now
so finally I just put on the dog at the
park so you eating healthy stuff eating
healthy well I have a friend she's
determined to get me healthy
she says Louie I'm gonna turn you around
I go where you better bring another
person so you eating like vegetable
stuff what you eat well she brings me
food she said I brought you a kale shake
I don't know about you but kale gives me
the shakes yeah yeah yeah I said bring
me a cake shake yeah cuz what's that I
go you take a hunk of cake and throw it
in the shake because I don't know if you
know this but cake will kill kale it's
the natural enemy of kale enemy but she
goes by organically in Louie buy organic
have you ever shopped Organa you know
you got all four how much are the
organic bananas they're $2.99 upon how
much are the other bananas they're free
no one wants him
I'll take the free bananas and some
organic stickers yeah yeah I mean you
know she does aren't you worried about
pesticides they go we used to run behind
the mosquito spraying trucks when I was
a kid did you really yeah we'd run
behind them there the trucks that spray
the Vasquez family would be right behind
him and no one cared yes we go home and
my dad will go what were you doing we
were ready we had the mosquitoes right
as drugs
everybody had fields buddy
Gilbert to the Cobo my dad would say
every single time sounds I get a traffic
car ride bikes they don't know Wells you
know
you